where did the creature come from the
hell is that thing
why did it attack hey with me advance
together
we may never have the answers to these
burning questions but one thing is
certain
if it wasn't for the valiant actions of
the legend the devastation would have
been far worse
buy beachfront property they said and i
did
yeah you're living in a rib cage while
many fought bravely it was a heroic new
legend who led the charge
people of the outlands you have a new
champion
the hero of harris valley the one and
only
newcastle
checkmate
going for a ride
the battle is far from overtime
the legends are already enjoying a
unique and challenging new environment
but that's not all the mysterious imc
armories will reward daring adventurers
willing to brave the dangers within
target down
time to break some hearts
[Music]
bring in the noise
there's no telling what threats lie
ahead legends i'm a diamond man you all
crush me whatever happens you'll need to
protect each other and let no one fall
all right let's finish this
real heroes get back up
approved by eduardo silva paid for by
the syndicate
you